hello you're watching entertainment week
coming up on the show as the release of
the comedy film the interview is
cancelled we assess the damage of the
cyber attack on sony as hammer horror
celebrates 80 years we speak to the
studio boss about its enduring appeal
priscilla presley tells us how a new
exhibition about elvis has brought the
memories flooding back
and the stars of the third night at the
museum film remember their co-star robin
williams
first this week's sony pictures shocked
hollywood by cancelling the release of
comedy the interview in the wake of a
cyber attack the film which pokes fun at
north korea's leader king jong-un was
pulled by cinemas after threats were
made by hackers is the latest blow to
sony following weeks of embarrassing
disclosures
among the numerous revelations that have
been brought to light are that angelina
jolie was called a minimally talented
spoiled brat in an email by producer
scott rodden it's emerged that oscar
winner jennifer lawrence was paid
considerably less than her male american
hustle co-stars and the hackers released
an early version of the script of the
next james bond film spectre and this is
the film that started it all
the cia would love it
if you two could take him out
hmm take him out take him out like for
drinks no no no take him out take out
like to dinner take him out to a meal
take him out and i'm joined by our
technology correspondent tom cheshire
and entertainment journalist steve
hargrave uh tom first of all how
far-reaching and how
serious has this hack been it was a
really big hack they got in there and
stole more than 100 terabytes of data
and rather using that for sort of
financial uh gain or benefit they just
dumped it all over the internet and
people have been combing through it ever
since then but then it had this other
stage where they're still releasing more
more and more material it came with
threats this time that anyone who was
going to go see the interview there
would be physical violence remember
september 11th and that's quite a
different thing for cyber attack to go
into the physical world and get homeland
security in america worried and looking
at it becoming a national security
matter
as they were saying um just a few days
ago
this has obviously been really
embarrassing for sony steve but how
damaging has it been well i think
massively so i mean for the people right
at the top who've been involved in these
email changes that have gone out it's
it's it's almost cripplingly
embarrassing for some of them who are
now sort of under pressure about their
jobs as you'd imagine i think the thing
that's really interesting about it
though is no one still knows exactly
what's at the heart of all of this that
these threats albeit very serious are
also
you know have no basis in a sense of
saying they are definitively from a
so-called terrorist attack or an act of
war is the words that's been banded
around some people online are saying
it's ridiculous to simulate that to
being an act of war it's merely someone
saying they don't want to see a film
there's lots of different levels but on
the level of being embarrassing to sony
it's horrible for them but those are the
juicy bits that i think the world is
much more interested in the real life
soap opera behind the scenes of all the
hollywood glamour when you peel that
apart and see all the stars embarrassed
about that george clooney embarrassed
about monuments men or as you say
jennifer lawrence not getting as much
money or people really close too late
and he's only twice of course now we've
heard revelations of her being called
you know where's the effect of spoil for
them really embarrassing for the rest of
the world rubbing their hands and saying
bring it on show us more of them really
interesting
tom initially people were saying this
could be north korea behind this what
are they now saying when this attack was
initially made they actually sent an
email threatening sony executives not
mentioning the interview at all in the
original uh hack itself no mention of
the interview is only after the media
started putting together this potential
link um that north korea was certainly
upset about the interview they said well
maybe this is a cyber attack steve sony
has pulled this film and does it set a
dangerous precedent um to give in to
these hackers and it also it shows how
much power they've got isn't there it
does and i think there is a danger and
some certainly the high profile actors
have been the ones who have said that's
a really dangerous president of sex
we've talked before about people's
artistic freedom the notion that you can
make comedy about anything make movies
about any subject and it's kind of okay
to a certain degree and what we are
seeing though is obviously a lot of
damage limitation from sony it's in
their interest to big up the fact that
they are fighting against some very
serious uh terrorist kind of entity and
something so there's there's a there's a
war of words going on certainly between
the unnamed sources and sony who have
got a lot of mopping up to do yeah will
there be more in the future thank you
both very much uh time now to catch up
on the rest of the week's entertainment
news there is flash photography coming
up
bill cosby won't be charged over claims
he attacked a 15 year old girl at the
playboy mansion in 1974.
she's one of at least 15 women who've
alleged the comedian sexually assaulted
them
the cast of selma a new film about
martin luther king have joined
campaigners demonstrating about the
death of eric garner who died after
police used a choke hold on him in
america stars wore t-shirts with the
slogan i can't breathe at the premiere
of their film in new york
madonna has described a leak of her new
songs as artistic rape and a form of
terrorism music pirates say the tracks
are from the singer's 13th studio album
where she claims the unreleased songs
are unfinished demos stolen long ago
the cast of stage show made in dagenham
including gemma artisan attended a rally
outside parliament to highlight the
gender pay gap and kasavian have topped
the nomination list for this year's nme
awards with an impressive eight nods
they're up against the arctic monkeys
and the libertines for best band among
others and villain of the year could go
to russell brand or nigel farage
trends in the movie business may come
and go but if there's one thing that
always remains the same its audiences
desire to be terrified for 80 years
hammer film studios have been giving a
host of ghouls and odysseys to cinemas
including the greatest monster of them
all count dracula and the horror
continues with their latest offering
woman in black angel of death
oh god
don't look at the eyes rex
tricked you your turn to hide
one
two
three
and the president of hammer film simon
oaks joins me now
lovely to see you this looks absolutely
terrifying the first film with daniel
radcliffe was a great success how hard
was it to follow that up
very hard i mean we obviously with the
first film we had the book and there'd
been a play in the west hand for 25
years and
we had jane goldman who's a great genre
writer and then daniel agreed to do the
first film after harry potter so it was
a sort of you know a serendipity moment
where everything came together at the
right time for this we had to create a
story from basically from the ground
upwards
and we wanted to create a separate film
not just a sequel but we didn't have
daniel obviously who
died at the end of the first one and uh
we wanted to move it on a time period so
we literally had to find inspiration
from other things and the thing that
inspired us was the war and evacuees
from london and so forth so it was it
was difficult but good but good fun
ham the horror has got such an amazing
history and how important is it for you
to honor that history at the same time
as keeping it fresh it's a tricky task i
would think it is i mean it is i mean i
i guess the thing about hammer is that
hammer had this great success between
the late 50s and early 70s but it
stopped making films really from then
and the horror super k came with
television in the early 80s so really it
just sort of closed down so what we had
to do was to imagine where would it have
gone in the last 30 years what should it
be doing now and i think
basically you know character-driven
story-driven movies like they did in the
50s and 60s keeps the heritage alive
often often referenced from or inspired
from novels from writing from pro from
literature um so acknowledging the
heritage but moving on because those
films were of their their time really
and horror is i mean such an interesting
genre and it's it's moved on so much
from these films hasn't it and if you
look at things like saw they're so
unbelievably shocking i mean how
difficult again is that for you to kind
of go down that road not at all not at
all because we won't go down that road i
mean i've been on record saying we won't
do what i call torture porn or
gonography we won't make those films i
don't have anything particular against
them i think they're fine whatever but i
think hammer you know we have to be we
do what we call elevated genre story
driven characters that you care about i
mean if the body count is 20 people by
10 minutes in you don't care about what
happens to them you care about perhaps
of daniel you care what happens to
phoebe in this in this film i think the
same about chloe moretz and let me in so
i think that i think our our approach is
our approach i think it's quite a
british approach frankly and i think
that's what we want to keep but you've
always been quite revolutionary i mean
in terms of censorship and historically
you've gone quite close to the bone
haven't you it was definitely
groundbreaking you know in the 50s and
60s and the marketing was incredible but
you know they got x rating for films
that wouldn't even get a u rating today
frankly so the world has moved on at the
moment we're talking about the the leaks
at sony has it made you kind of reassess
your security at all
anything that you do not not remotely i
mean listen you know i personally have
never written emails like that and sent
them i might have thought them uh i feel
very sorry for amy he's a brilliant
executive and and everybody involved
frankly i think the trouble with this is
there are like five or six issues all
going on at the same time it's not just
about them it's about the cinema owners
it's about censorship it's about freedom
of speech so many different issues now
we we just we just carry on we're fine
do you think it was the right decision
for them to pull the film you want me to
actually answer that gosh no i don't i
think they should have basically uh gone
ahead and then let the cinema owners who
basically the exhibitors decide if they
wanted to take the risk to show it but i
think sony should have pushed ahead with
it that's my personal opinion
thank you so much for your time thank
you
nearly 40 years after elvis presley died
the king of rock and roll is still a
source of fascination for his millions
of fans now they can get an insight into
the man behind the music as an
exhibition including hundreds of his
belongings opens at the o2 in london his
former wife priscilla presley gave sky's
richard suchet a
tour can't walk out
these are a few of the things that we're
putting on exhibit here first time ever
actually many of the things first time
ever even for elvis presley enterprises
so we figured that this would be
something that the english fans or
people from great britain
are actually all over could come and see
how he lived his personal life as you
can see what he carried in his billfold
what his personal belongings were things
that he liked
surrounding him records that he played
the qatar that he used
some of the
the decor that was and still is at
graceland right now so this really gives
a personalization of who elvis presley
was this is exactly how it looked
um elvis
spent much time playing at that piano
especially early mornings when we'd come
home from the theater i would watch
movies sometimes till six o'clock in the
morning
you have helped to prolong
um his his memory i mean of course he's
got many fans but you've kind of helped
keep these things these artifacts in the
public eye so what was your relationship
like in those years after well i'll
explain it this way i think i i was um i
had the biggest compliment from my
daughter two years ago when she was on
national television in
cali and um in the states
and one of the questions was what was
that like when your parents had divorced
and she answered that
she never knew that we were divorced
that we were the same way together when
we were divorced as we were when we were
together when we were married so we were
and we were very very good friends and
we cared very much for each other we
still loved each other i have to ask you
what are your
two or three favorite things in the in
the exhibition oh my gosh
one of them was a letter that he sent to
colonel parker when he came out of the
army
when it was time for him to come home in
the telegram he states that he doesn't
want to have a fanfare welcoming he
wants to be treated like every soldier
that served in their time and i thought
that was very touching and it really
shows a sign of elvis that very few of
us would know you think being a
celebrity you know give me the fanfare
give me the welcoming i want everyone
around but he wanted to be treated like
any other soldier they've all been in
there serving their time so he was very
sensitive to that and he got what he
wanted so he came in very stealthy and
was welcomed by his friends and family
brilliant well thank you so much
appreciate it
coming up jim carrey dumbs down for the
sequel to one of his biggest hits we'll
give our verdict on that and the rest of
the week's releases
one of the year's biggest shocks was the
death of robin williams who left a
legacy of classic films from mrs
doubtfire to good morning vietnam this
week audiences will get to see the
comedian in one of his last roles as the
third and final night at the museum is
released joe mccaltuck spoke to the cast
hi there
i bet you're not so mean are you huh
wanna play fetch
go fetch
wow you suggest a different plan what
when you sort of assemble such a gifted
comic cast and sort of yourself
obviously owen wilson ricky ray steve
coogan rebel wilson um is there sort of
an element of comedy one-upmanship going
on with you guys on set i you know i've
never felt that people try to out-gag
each other on a movie i mean i think
people try to you know you want to just
do your best you want to you know sort
of be you know because it's someone that
you are a fan of you want to just kind
of you know i mean you know like with
rob and williams anytime i was ever
working with robin i you know i was such
a fan that like i would want to try to
be good
you mentioned uh robin williams there i
mean obviously when you first see him on
screen here it sort of hits you knew for
the first time yeah it's you know
obviously incredibly sad you won't be
seeing him again in a new film but is
that the beauty of your industry the
fact that he can leave such a legacy in
in 10 15 years time people can go watch
this film and it's a fitting way for him
to go out well he's he made so many
great movies and and so many incredible
performances and live performances and
you know what he did on comic relief and
just you know there he just left an
incredible amount of work uh behind and
so you know that's going to live on
forever for sure
i always find it
as strange and poignant to see
actors on screen
either years after they've died
or weeks after they've died
there's something about
an after an echo
that a film actor is able to leave
behind that no no other
craft does leave behind and joe joins me
now joe watching robin williams on
screen it is really poignant it is
really sad and especially because his
character he plays president roosevelt
and it's quite a fatherly figure yeah i
mean it the first time he sort of
appears on the screen it really hits you
i said there in that vt and that pity
your stomach really you think i'm not
going to see him again in new work but
thank god the writers gave him a decent
send-off in the movie because it could
have been all so different i mean he has
a
final speech doesn't it it's very
heartfelt touching speech there's
obviously packed full of pathos pathos
sorry because it's more poignant now we
know what's happened
i mean away from robin williams i think
this is actually a pretty decent film i
mean it's a wrapping up the trilogy as
well of the of the franchise it's
unashamedly silly isn't it and it's fun
and i think the cast look like they're
having fun and i think you you could go
and you could pick worse films to take
the kids to the cinema to over christmas
and it's such a good idea as a sort of a
franchise because it does get people
interested really geekily in going to
museums i mean it spawned people staying
overnight
it's a great idea isn't it i mean i
think we've all walked around because
we're geeks around the british museum or
other museums said you know what could
these objects talk to us about it it's a
good idea i think it's now the format
has now stretched to sort of breaking
point i think another one wilson is very
funny in it isn't she yes there's one
from where where's he from pitch perfect
bridesmaid she's got a mockney cockney
accent going on there and she hooks up
with ben uh still as uh neanderthal uh
fella here you know it's a lot of fun i
think it's basically like a pantos it's
perfect for the christmas season it's
you know it's a silly film but i think
it's a lot of fun okay talking about
silly films um dumb and dumber too
before you tell me what you think of it
and what i think of it let's have a look
let's call her it's ringing
whoever this is we're in the middle of
something very important here this is
your dad what hey guys i know this is
weird timing but i got to take this it's
my dead dad she's got me on hold
i mean i actually couldn't think of
anything worse than sitting in the
cinema and watching this is that fair
well i mean you're talking to the wrong
person because the first one when it was
released i got told down to told to calm
down by a cinema attendant because i was
laughing so hard this tapped into my
inner 12 year old this movie four year
olds
well you know
we developed slower than
you women obviously but you know i think
if you hated the first you're gonna
despise the second because it hasn't
changed at all i mean they're still
girling away punching each other in the
groining and finding it hilarious but if
you enjoyed the first one there's still
a couple of good laughs that the sequels
aren't generally as good as the first
it's got yeah is it does it one of the
problems is it's not going to stand out
because it's 20 years on and you've got
such big memories of the first if you
enjoyed it that you know so it hasn't
got enough big laughs i don't think you
know i think you need five big laughs
apparently to make a really successful
comedy on the big screen you've just
seen one of them not the catheter moment
this scene here is excellent but i think
jim carrey's still the most gifted
physical comedian there is on the big
screen his partnership with jeff daniels
works i'm not sure how it works you know
you go from watching the newsroom with
jeff daniels to him being uh just
completely stupid if it's the same
person can you but it's called dumb and
dumber lucy you know if you're not going
to get a joke about marcel proust are
you no it is one and it does what it
says on the tin exactly and i spoke to
jim carrey because comedy's changed a
lot in 20 years you know it's got more
nuance now hasn't it and dramady and
smaller laughs and he's all for these
big silly laughs you know it doesn't
have any pretense at all you know it's
just gonna it's just gonna work you you
know in the in the
the lowest to the highest vibrations you
know it's like it doesn't it doesn't uh
it's not there's no arrogance about it
you know and there's no ego in comedy to
me so uh you can do all the nuance you
want but uh but if you don't make them
laugh
then you don't make them laugh you know
to me
i'm not crazy about going to see
comedies where i go
that's interesting you know and i'm not
laughing i want people to pee their
pants if you're over 30 you'll go and
see out of curiosity i think if you're
under 30 you might really think who the
hell are these two old blokes sort of
you know on the screen in the silly
beard
no i think when you look at things like
um the jump street series with channing
tatum at the moment i think you look at
those ones you look at the seth rogen
films obviously we've been talking about
that with the interview that is the new
sort of big screen comedy this feels
dated i think if you like the first
you'll like this one
maybe don't go see at the cinema watch
it on a friday night we've had a couple
of drinks at home on sky not for me
anyway finally exodus with christian
bale playing moses this should be
interesting
how do you know moses
you know how i know him
so you're not his sister then
of course not
place your arm on the table
ramesses
don't take this any further
don't take this any further what
do not take this any further are you
quite sure about that
get your hand off it or use it now
this is ridley scott christian bale
moses i think the clips don't do it
justice i mean you just snickered there
i mean i think it does look like
campers christmas really and you know
they've run out of guy liner in the
whole of the uk i think after making
this a fake tan but i think if you get
past that is proper old school biblical
epic i mean there used to be two a penny
didn't they and i think they had this
solomon slightly pious tone and they
sort of fell out of fashion this this is
full of life and vivaciousness he plays
the moses story like a political drama
it's ridley scott so he's great at the
big epic battle scenes you know the the
10 plagues of egypt are brutal you know
this is the wrath of god on the big
screen and the money shot the parting of
the red sea is tremendous it's one of
the best scenes i've seen all year on
screen it falls slightly short with the
slightly hammy personal scenes away from
christian bells moses and joel
edgerton's ramesses there they're
fantastic as two warring brothers you've
got sigourney weaver in the cast ben
kingsley they don't know
again yeah sir ben king he does they
don't really do much i think if he had
fleshed those characters out it could
have been as good as gladiator i really
think it potentially is that good it's
not as good as gladiator i think that
when you think back to the counsellor
and stuff you know and prometheus it's
probably his best film since gladiator
and i think try and get past the fake
tan and the eyeliner and all that kind
of stuff and perfect boxing day fair
your turkey hangover two and a half
hours sit there let it all wash over you
because it's a spectacle it's epic i'd
recommend it joe thank you so much
and that is all for now but coming up on
entertainment week in the new year can
benedict cumberbatch triumph at awards
season will bring you all the
nominations including the baftas and
golden globe nominee ethan hawk will be
here to talk about his critically
acclaimed role in boyhood